♪
PETE: NEW REPORTS PAINT A
DEVASTATING PICTURE OF THE
WORSENING CRISIS ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
FILINGS FROM JUNE SHOW OFFICIALS
ENCOUNTERED MORE THAN 200,000
ILLEGALS FOR THE FOURTH STRAIGHT
MONTH.
CARLEY: AND EVEN MORE
DISTURBING, 56 OF THOSE
APPREHENDED YEAR HAVE BEEN
FLAGGED ON THE TERRORIST
SCREENING DATABASE.
WILL: SENATOR IF RON JOHNSON
JUST RETURNED FROM THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY, AND AND HE JOINS
US NOW.
SENATOR, GREAT TO HAVE YOU,
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
WILL: NUMBER 56 ON TERROR WATCH
LIST.
I BELIEVE THAT NUMBER DOESN'T
JUST EXCEED WHERE WE WERE
EARLIER THIS YEAR MONTH BY
MONTH, BUT THE TOTAL LAST YEAR.
IT'S -- HOWEVER IT IS, IT'S AN
ASTOUNDING NUMBER, SENATOR.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THESE
56 INDIVIDUALS?
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANY MORE
INFORMATION OUT THERE, BUT WHAT
TYPE OF INDIVIDUALS ARE ON THE
WATCH LIST GETTING FLAGGED THAT
WE'RE NOW ENCOUNTERING AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> WELL, WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT'S PROBABLY JUST THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED.
WE DON'T EVEN CALL IT
APPREHENSIONS ANYMORE.
SINCE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
MORE THAN 3 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
CROSSED THE BORDER ILLEGALLY,
OVER 6,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
THE LAST FOUR MONTHS T -- IT'S
BEEN OVER 7,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
THERE'S A LARGE OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE THE KNOWN OR UNKNOWN
GOTAWAYS, AND THAT REPRESENTS
THE MASS SECURITY THREAT ARE.
AGAIN, WE'RE SO OVERWHELMED BY
THE APPREHENSIONS THAT THERE
CREATES OPENINGS FOR DEADLY
DRUGS AS WELL AS VERY UNSAVORY
CHARACTERS COMING FROM OVER A
150 NATIONS NOW, IS WHAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED.
OVER 150 NATIONS.
WE HAVE A COMPLETELY OPEN
BORDER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION SO BELIEVE
YOUS TO IT.
THEY WON'T EVEN ADMIT IT'S A
PROBLEM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
REALIZE THE SOUTHWEST BORDER IS
100% CONTROLLED ON MEXICAN SIDE
OF THE BORDER BY DRUG CARTELS,
BY HUMAN TRAFFICKING CARTELS.
IT'S ABOUT AN $18 BILLION
BUSINESS BY BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
CALCULATION FROM ONE OF OUR
BRIEFINGS, $18 BILLION, AND AND
THAT JUST ACCOUNTS FOR THE
PEOPLE WE'VE ENCOUNTERED.
SO THIS IS -- WE ARE PUMPING,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BEING PUMPED INTO THESE
ORGANIZATIONS BEING FACILITATED,
THIS MULTIBILLION DOLLAR
BUSINESS MODEL IS BEING
FACILITATED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
OPEN BORDER POLICY.
IT'S SICK.
9 AND THE HUMAN DEGRADATIONS, I
WISH I COULD CONVEY TO YOUR
LISTENERS HOW PROFOUNDLY
DISTURBING IT IS TO ENCOUNTER A
6 OR 7-YEAR-OLD GIRL
UNACCOMPANIED, ALL THEY HAVE IS
THEIR BIRTH CERTIFICATE AND A
PHONE NUMBER AND ADDRESS OF
SOMEBODY KNOWN IN THE U.S.
IF THEY LOSE THAT, WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEM?
BILL MELUGIN IS DOING A GREAT
JOB REPORTING.
HE WAS AT THE BORDER WITH US,
TOLD US THAT A FEW WEEKS OR A
FEW MONTHS BEFORE THAT VERY SPOT
A SIMILARLY YOUNG GIRL HAD JUST
BEEN RAPED X IF THEY WERE BEING
GIVEN MEDICAL ATTENTION BID
BORDER AND CUSTOM PATROL.
THE SEX SLAVES CAUSED BY THIS
ILLEGAL FLOW, THAT THAT NEEDS TO
BE HIGHLIGHTED.
BUT, AGAIN, OTHER THAN FOX NEWS,
A FEW OTHER OUTLETS, THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA'S NOT DOWN
THERE.
THEY'RE COVERING UP FOR JOE
BIDEN.
THEY ARE COMPLICIT IN THIS, THEY
ARE CORRUPT.
PETE: SPEAKING OF -- WELL SAID,
BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU FOR GOING THERE.
I WISH ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
WOULD ACTUALLY GO, TALK ABOUT
IT.
OF COURSE THEY WON'T SO YOU ARE.
THANKS FOR DOING THAT.
YOU'VE ALSO BEEN ALL OVER THE
STORY, SPEAKING OF NOT TELLING
THE STORY, OF HUNTER BIDEN.
THAT STORY WAS SUPPRESSED, WE
KNOW, BY SOCIAL MEDIA AGAINST
"THE NEW YORK POST."
NOW "THE NEW YORK POST" IF HAS
ANOTHER DATA POINT.
HERE'S A PORTION OF WHAT THEY'VE
NOW LEARNED IN LOOKING AT THE
LAPTOP.
HUNTER BIDEN OFTEN WOULD HUDDLE
WITH HIS DAD IN THE DAYSES OR
EVEN MINUTES AFTER OF HIGH
PROFILE MEETINGS.
HUNTER BIDEN WAS WINED AND DINED
BY BILLIONAIRE OLIGARCHS IN
MOSCOW INCLUDING ONE NOW WANTED
FOR MURDER.
FOUR DAYS AFTER HIS RETURN,
HUNTER BIDEN MET WITH VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN AGAIN AT THE
NAVAL OBSERVATORY.
IT GOES ON WITH EXAMPLE IF AFTER
EXAMPLE.
YET JOE BIDEN CONTINUES TO SAY
HE KNEW NOTHING, SENATOR.
IF.
>> WELL, THE MEDIA CONTINUES TO
COVER UP FOR HIM.
SENATOR GRASSLEY AND I, WE TRIED
TO WARN AMERICANS.
WE ISSUED OUR REPORT IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2020 TO HOE THE
VAST WEB OF FOREIGN
ENTANGLEMENTS, THE CORRUPTION OF
BIDEN INC., BUT THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA NOT ONLY IGNOREDDED IT,
THEY ACCUSED US OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
SO WE HAD 50 INTELLIGENCE
PROFESSIONALS ALSO PERFORM THEIR
OWN INFORMATION OPERATION.
AS THEY SAID, THE HUNTER LAPTOP
WAS BASICALLY A RUSSIAN
INFORMATION OPERATION.
SO IT'S BEEN COVERED UP.
IT SHOWS THE COMPRESS
FELICITY -- COMPLICITY AND
CORRUPTION OF NOT ONLY THE NEWS
MEDIA, BUT OUR FEDERAL AGENCIES.
THIS IS A HUGE SCANDAL, BUT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA'S COVERING IT
UP, ASK IS WE KNOW NOW
CONCLUSIVELY BECAUSE THE LAPTOP
IS SUCH A TREASURE-TROVE OF
INFORMATION THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
WAS LYING TO US AS A CANDIDATE,
HE CONTINUES TO LIE, THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA COVER UP FOR
HIM.
CARLEY: IF REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE, I THINK
HUNTER BIDEN SHOULD BE EXPECTING
A SUBPOENA, SO MORE INFORMATION